[Musica]
fino all'ultimo ho provato ho sperato e
ho chiesto anche in ginocchio di
presentarmi qua con questi fogli che
sarebbero il mio ted
consigliabile a tutti e andarmene
speravo di fare cose invece doveva
parlare quindi lascio questi fogli qua
ho pensato a quale fosse il modo
migliore per
esprimere un'idea un'opinione un
pensiero e trasmetterlo all'altro quindi
ripercorso
la storia dell'umanità
fino ad arrivare alla mia infanzia
e
mi sono ricordato che il modo migliore
il pivot capito le cose non era quando
mi dicevano a questo non fare questo
questo è giusto questo non è giusto
questo è sbagliato il modo migliore da
quando mi raccontavano una storia non mi
raccontavano una favola e quindi stasera
farò così deciso di fare in questo modo
ho deciso che racconterò ho scelto tre
parole per stasera tutte e tre
estrapolate una da una favola e due da
una storia
ora immaginiamo di essere in senegal
dopo cena
ci sediamo all'ombra di un baobab tutti
in cerchio come fanno i bambini e poi
ognuno a turno racconta una storia una
favola ognuno fa il suo terzo alla fine
è questo
e
cos'è questo immagine cosa rappresenta
un colibrì
nella foresta c'è un incendio un
grandissimo incendio le fiamme inizia a
bruciare ovunque tutto quanto e anima
inizia a scappare
si nascondono che vicino al fiume che
sopra gli alberi e tutti scappano
intanto le fiamme avanzano aumentano
si nascondono a un certo punto trovano
diffuso vicino al fiume e
iniziamo a parlare sul da farsi come
possiamo spegnere l'incendio che
possiamo fare come in che modo possiamo
diciamo spegnere queste fiamme a quel
punto passa il colibrì questo piccolo
uccellino si dirige verso il fiume si
butta in acqua
prende una goccia d'acqua perché è la
portata massima che al suo becco
prendere una goccia d'acqua
torna verso le fiamme e lascia cadere la
goccia
ovviamente il fuoco nemmeno se ne
accorge non se ne rende conto nemmeno
per percepisce questa goccia però il
colibrì
continua torna verso il fiume prendere
un'altra goccia d'acqua e la butta sulle
fiamme prima che a quel punto la
guardano lo guardano ma questo che sta
facendo il leone si avvicina di fama tu
cosa pensi di fare che stai facendo e
con il video guarda e fa anche sto
cercando di spegnere l'incendio ma tu
così piccola cioè pensi di spegnere
l'incendio
a quel punto i libri si ferma in aria
con le sigarette piccoline risponde così
io intanto faccio la mia parte
io nella mia vita ho conosciuto
tantissimi possibile
tanti ne ho conosciuti altri sette oggi
prima di me che loro piccolo ha fatto la
loro parte però i miei colibrì
riferimento i miei primi colibrì sono
mio padre e mia madre
che
[Applauso]
che 30 anni fa decisero di partire dal
senegal per venire in italia hanno fatto
un piccolo passo hanno fatto la loro
parte e se io sono qui su questo ted 30
anni dopo e grazie a quel piccolo passo
è
la seconda parola che ho scelto
invece ascolto
questa immagine andrea camilleri è una
foto che ho scattato ad agrigento
e lo scrittore camilleri è uno dei miei
scrittori preferiti
e ho scelto camilleri associandolo
all'ascolto perché questa storia che
racconterò è un episodio che è successo
a lui il giovane camilleri era a fare
questo esame di accesso
all'accademia di arte drammatica a roma
insomma fa questo esame si impegna fa
l'esame sia orarie che è scritto
appena finisce il professore lo guarda e
dice il signor camilleri sappia che io
non condivido nulla di quello che lei ha
detto e scritto in queste due ore a
rivederla
il giovane andrea un po sconsolato va
dal professore arrivederci e se ne va
a quel punto noi convinti non essere
stato ammesso torna in albergo prende il
suo zaino ci mette un po di cose
magliette pantaloncini e si fa a fare
una bella vacanza in giro per roma
insomma spa 10 giorni di vacanza visto
tutti poste parte girato ma i monti su e
giù
dopo dieci giorni torna e la sua stanza
d'albergo ad attenderlo c'erano tre
telegrammi scritti da suo padre apre il
telegramma che c'era scritto se è stato
ammesso col massimo dei voti
all'accademia a camilleri stupito
sorpreso prende lo zaino e corre su di
un'accademia arriva in accademia
il professore lo guarda e fa signor
camilleri
come mai si è presentato alle elezioni
con 6 giorni di ritardo dall'inizio il
giovane andrea lo guardi fama professore
dal momento che lei mi dice che non
condivide il professore lo interrompe
alta aspetta
non condividere non significa che le
opinioni dell'altro siano shock no
possono essere idee intelligenti
solo che io non le condivido
perché ho scelto questo episodio perché
in questo episodio si vede che giovane
camilleri non ha ascoltato il professore
confondo l'insegnamento di questo
episodio è che bisogna sempre ascoltare
fino in fondo le ragioni dell'altro
e difficile una cosa molto difficile
io ci provo
tutti i giorni perché alla fine
allenamento non è facile
però la mia domanda è se io quando
ascolto fino in fondo le ragioni
dell'altro mi sento dire quando magari
esprimo una mia opinione
una mia idea il mio pensiero
mi sento dire sono tutti uguali ci
devono stare a casa loro vengono qui
solo per rubare la loro cultura
incompatibile con la nostra
vedono le donne come oggetto
quando è che o poi riuscirò scoprire da
intelligente nell'altro in quale momento
adesso siamo arrivati a
va bene vi racconto un piccolo episodi
che è successo a me ormai sono passati
dieci anni a firenze
insomma ero arrivato a firenze da poco
avevo il mio borsone la pallavolo e non
conosciamo ancora le vie di firenze e
quindi col mio borso che mi avvicino
verso una persona cioè chiedendo
informazione mi avvicino con un borsone
senza lasciarmi parlare mi dice non ho
niente non ho soldi
io quel punto
ho tirato fuori 2 euro l'ora d'aria
perché i miei genitori
[Musica]
ah beh bisogna sempre aiutare chi è meno
fortunato no
l'ultima parola è il viaggio
questa è la capitale del senegal a dakar
questo è il porto adesso faremo un
viaggio tutti insieme sanremo su questa
nave
e andremo in un posto
però prima leggiamo questo pensiero di
terzani
viaggiare ha senso solo se si ritorna
con qualche risposta nella valigia
io due anni fa sono tornato in senegal
con i miei genitori e la mia famiglia
dopo tanti anni la prima settimana è
dedicata ai parenti avvisare tutti i
parenti
poi abbiamo visto il paese abbiamo visto
la città e poi con mia sorella abbiamo
deciso di fare un viaggio
è la risposta che ho trovato nella
valigia
durante il viaggio
è stata questa piccola isola
questa isola si chiama isola di cuore
è un è un puntino in mezzo all'oceano
proprio piccolissimo è un chilometro e
3d lunghi la grid e lunghezza e 300
metri di larghezza
quindi in un giorno riesce a visitarla
tutta
eppure questa piccola isola
questa questo punto in mezzo all'oceano
atlantico per tantissimi secolo è stata
contesa da tutta europa
perché uno perché è un punto strategico
cuda core e 6 punti i cannoni
poi direzionali verso l'america
verso l'africa e verso l'europa
quindi vedi prima che essere visto dal
punto di vista militare
questo tra poco
però governo è soltanto un punto
strategico vorrei anche un continente un
continente dove sono passate tante
persone tanti spiriti corea
diciamo che è un continente dell'anima
sono tante storie e una storia che
voglio raccontarvi è quella che non so
se la conoscete trovata gore passavano
gli schiavi prima di arrivare in america
in europa
veniamo presi dal continente africano
poi con un traghetto da dakar portati in
questa piccola isola
che a vederla sembra anche se molto
carina vista da fuori e bella colorata
tutti i colori
poi passeggio per le vie
qui veniamo portati gli schiavi
e dove viene dove venivano messi poi
questi schiavi
in questa piccola casa mesones plastica
la casa degli schiavi erano
piccole gabbie di due metri e 60 per 2
metri e 60 all'interno si stavano dai 15
ai 20 schiavi considerando che ci sono
due metri non ha testato a pensare
quanto potrebbe essere stretti abbiamo
messe qua dentro arrivavano le donne da
una parte gli uomini dall'altra i
bambini da una parte e le bambine
dall'altra
abbiamo messi qua dentro nutriti con i
legumi pesati ogni giorno è una volta
che raggiungevano il giusto peso
erano pronti per partire
e passavano da un'altra porta che veniva
chiamata la porta del non ritorno
è semplice il motivo
abbiamo messi in questa barchetta e al
largo che aspettava un galeone
si aspettava qui allargo un galeone
veniamo messi dentro e
padre in europa madre in america e
magari figlio in sud america
e quindi questo succedeva quello intere
famiglie divise per sempre separate non
si trovano più ma non c'era soltanto
questo c'è l'obiettivo aveva soltanto
avere degli schiavi l'obiettivo è anche
svuotare il continente africano
svuotarlo del suo capitale umano
prenderla povero perché vi dico questo
perché vi ho raccontato questa storia
perché spesso andiamo a pensare che
flussi migratori adesso non ci
riguardano che sono cose a noi anche
perché noi non c'entriamo niente
però la storia insegna che tutto è
iniziato da questo
come diceva de gregori la storia siamo
noi attenzione nessuno si senta escluso
nessuno
ricordiamo c'è questa cosa
poi un'altra cosa che volevo dire è che
è importante aprire i propri orizzonti
apre il punto di vista aprire il proprio
pensiero adesso mi sta venendo in mente
un pensiero da biologo sono anche
biologo e quindi fare un parallelismo
che mi è venuto fuori mentre parlavo
direttrice del laboratorio parole del
ted e mi ha raccontato che nel xix
secolo circa ventesimo secolo in europa
c'era una malattia che viene chiamata la
malattia reale la conoscete
l'emofilia
l'emofilia parte del sangue
difficoltà di popolazione il sangue
quindi facili emorragie
materiale perché perché era la malattia
che si verificava molto spesso tra i
reali perché tra i reali
perché l'emofilia la marca che sono su
un gene il genere da parte di dna che
codifica che
contiene un informazione magari
considera l'informazione del
dell'emofilia
se all'interno di una famiglia ai questa
malattia e tende a
sposarti tra i familiari tende anche a
rafforzare questa malattia perché ho
fatto questo esempio perché se tu hai un
pensiero solo un pensiero unico e ne
parli solo con persone che la pensano
come te
quel pensiero si rafforza se tu invece
riesce avere più punti di vista a ad
aprirti a vedere altri orizzonti quel
pensiero magari può essere giusto perron
e vero che ci sono tanti altri giusti
insieme
allora
ho citato de gregori vari scrittori
se me lo permettete
essendo pure o scrittore pure a citare
me stesso quindi leggerò un pezzo che ho
scritto
io non sono mai stato su un barcone
disperso nel mare
non ho mai buttato un mio amico in mare
perché tanto è morto
non sono mai stato vittima di bullismo
né di omofobia e di discriminazione
non sono mai morto di fame e di sete
non sono mai stato ucciso perché nero
perché donna o semplicemente perché
diverso da te non sono mai morto per la
malattia che avrei potuto curare con
l'antibiotico dall'euro non sono mai
immigrato perché qui non c'è lavoro per
me non c'è futuro non sono mai morto
bombardato mentre ero a scuola
io
scappando dalla guerra
non ho mai vissuto per anni in un campo
profughi
non ho mai perso la mia casa a causa di
un terremoto di un uragano o di uno
tsunami
e non ho mai perso i miei cari dello
stesso motivo io non sono mai stata la
stazione a elemosinare può pulire vetri
il semaforo non ho mai lavorato per tre
euro allora perché nella nuova
alternativa
non sono mai stato arrestato per eccesso
di solidarietà ma soprattutto non ho mai
detto tanto a me non può succedere
perché il mondo da quando gira
da quando esiste gira come dicevano gli
eventi
questo e molto altro io non l'ho mai
provato sulla mia pelle
eppure non riesco ad essere indifferente
a tutto questo
mai si chiama empatia umanità
conserviamolo
[Applauso]
adesso
riavvolgiamo il nastro torniamo indietro
all'inizio tutto quello che ho detto nel
mezzo è una scelta mostra potete
prenderlo no però poi ripartire
dall'inizio torniamo indietro
voi ricordate lui
il colibrì
vi ricordate anche la goccia d'acqua che
prendeva
allora io credo con lui e quella goccia
d'acqua
io penso che ognuno di noi ha qualcosa
di straordinario da donare grande o
piccolo che sia quindi vi auguro quello
che auguro a me stasera in futuro di
avere sempre la forza la pazienza
l'entusiasmo e la generosità la
generosità di fare la nostra parte di
trovare la nostra goccia d'acqua da
donare
chi vi è intorno ve ne sarà grato grazie
per l'ascolto
[Applauso]